I would focus on I would focus on a set
of individual questions just you know
what what can I do that make sense in
this in this broad context of of this
extraordinary world next 20 30 40 years
you know what what will I do that will
be successful and contribute in a
meaningful way towards good
globalization which i think is the key
challenge of the 20 21st century and
even be in the technology domain it can
be in the it can be in the public policy
domain it could be you know personal
professionally but that's I think that's
the frame and I think I think would be
good for people to think about the
long-term horizon so so any frame but
you know where do I see myself in 30
years 40 years 50 years and I think
people don't ask that